jean marc jancovici ça fait des années
que vous tenter d'influencer les
décideurs français qu'ils soient
politiques entreprises syndicats pour
qu'ils agissent sur le climat est ce que
l'été que nous venons de connaître c'est
à dire marquer par la canicule la
sécheresse les incendies et plus
généralement les intempéries pour vous
est-ce que cet été a été le déclic celui
de la prise de conscience du dérèglement
climatique dans selon un sondage qui a
été publiée par vos confrères je suis le
frangin de ce matin non là on s'est
regardé l il ya un besoin ça c'est fait
mais il faut espérer il faut espérer
qu'ils sont convergents
il ya un français sur cinq de plus qui
dit avoir réalisé cet été que les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
était déjà là
avant cet été il y en avait trois sur
cinq disent en être conscient maintenant
on arriverait à 4 sur 5 maintenant il
faut voir ce que c'est ce qui s'appelle
conscient il faut voir ce que ça
signifie en termes d'efforts qu'on est
capable de porter seul ou bien de
souhaiter pour la société dans son
ensemble
voilà donc il sait que certainement
passer quelque chose cet été lors du
déclic il ya un tout petit marqueur
alors il vaut ce qu'il vaut 1 qui est le
nombre d'invitations pour des émissions
à la rentrée que j'ai reçus mois merci
d'avoir privilégié celle de france info
en tout cas
vous savez en retour midi à sa porte et
donc le et effectivement il est en
augmentation significative par rapport
aux rentrées précédentes voilà donc
c'est une préoccupation est il faut
s'habituer à vivre ce qu'on a vécu cet
été alors ça va devenir la norme alors
ça va pas devenir la norme ça va devenir
la borne inférieure malheureusement
c'est ça devenir pierre bien sûr ça va
devenir pire mais ça on le sait depuis
très longtemps 2 en fait le problème du
réchauffement climatique c'est qu'il
faut depuis toujours essayer d'éviter
quelque chose qui ne s'est pas produit
et de faire en sorte qu'il ne se
produise jamais c'est très très
difficile pour les animaux que nous
sommes on n'a pas l'habitude de se
comporter comme ça en général on voit
d'abord les dangers puis une fois qu'on
les a vus on fait ce qu'il faut pour que
ça se répète pas là le problème du
réchauffement climatique c'est qu'il ya
une inertie absolument considérable un
effet cliquet dans le système c'est à
dire qu'une fois que le co2 dans
l'atmosphère il m'est très très très
longtemps s'évacuer est donc une fois
qu'on a dégradé le climat peut pas
revenir en arrière et non seulement on
peut pas revenir en arrière mais tant
qu'il ya une tonne qui continuent à être
émises par les activités humaines
quelque part le climat continue à se
dégrader ce qui veut dire que ce qui
nous est arrivé cet été c'est
malheureusement absolument certain qu'il
va y avoir pire dans les années qui
viennent c'est à dire que même si on
arrêtait tout ce qui évidemment n'est
pas possible aujourd'hui d'un coup de
baguette magique ça continuerait pendant
combien de temps alors ça dépend ça
s'aggraverait pendant combien ça dépend
des conséquences qu'on regarde après
arrêt total des émissions la température
atmosphérique s'arrête d'augmenter ça
c'est très rapide par contre là
températures océaniques en particulier
des couches profondes de l'océan
continue d'augmenter le niveau de la mer
va continuer de monter pendant des
millénaires après qu'on ait arrêté les
émissions totalement les glaces vont
continuer les glaces polaires en
particulier ont continué à fondre
pendant des siècles des millénaires
après qu'on ait arrêté les émissions et
la réponse des écosystèmes à des
conditions qui seront devenus
différentes ça va également prendre très
longtemps sert aujourd'hui même à
conditions climatiques constante terre
ce même si demain matin on disait ma le
climat ne va pas se dégrader par rapport
à ce qu'il est aujourd'hui il ya déjà 10
% de la forêt française qui va mourir
donc pas par répétition de condition que
les arbres ne peuvent plus supporter
donc le temps de réponse derrière il ya
un certain de choses qui derrière
l'arrêt des émissions continuent de se
dégrader
de façon plus ou moins rapide on est
loin de là du zéro pour cent de ses
actions se sont pas arrêtés oui c'était
jean marc jancovici on est incapable
aujourd'hui de dire qu'on va mettre
qu'on va faire zéro émission de gaz à
effet serre en revanche le gouvernement
les ministres les politiques aujourd'hui
ont invoqué qui reviennent à leur bouche
c'est le mot sobriété le gouvernement
invite les français à faire attention à
leur consommation
d'énergie des branches et les prises
électriques lorsqu'on part en vacances
couper le wifi ou baisser la
climatisation est ce que ça ça sert
vraiment à quelque chose alors juste
pour finir sur le
sur la partie émission oui en fait il ya
quand même un engagement de la
communauté internationale à ce que les
émissions humaines soit totalement
supprimés d'ici à 2050 pour ça il faut
les baisser de 5% chaque genre 2022 oui
ça laisse 28 ans à dire en gros le pas
de temps qui sépare l'âge de nos enfants
de notre propre âge un surf pour pour
donner un ordre de grandeur et il
faudrait que dans ce laps de temps on
est supprimé la totalité de ce qui a
fait la civilisation industrielle parce
que c'est les combustibles fossiles
qu'on fait la civilisation industrielle
bon je pense que pour le moment les gens
qui déclare sa réalise pas bien ce à
quoi il s'engage enfin ma parenthèse
alors sur les économies d'énergie en
fait les petits gestes ça marche pas on
peut pas faire des grosses économies et
des petits gestes donc si on veut faire
des gros économie faut faire des gros
geste des comme vous nous dites quoi
arriver à zéro où sont les gros geste
chez les français ils sont dans les
déplacements il faut rappeler que en ce
qui concerne ce qu'on appelle l'énergie
finale c'est celle qui rentre dans une
machine quelque part qui nous rend un
service que ce soit la caméra qui est en
train de me filmer ou bien une voiture
qui est en train éventuellement des
placer quelqu'un en ce moment c'est le
pétrole qui domine en france c'est pas
du tout l'électricité donc débrancher le
wifi ok c'est bien mais enfin partir en
vacances en train c'est mieux pour ceux
qui ont la chance de partir en vacances
donc il ya un qu'est ce que j'ai à dire
il faut bien voir que les gros geste
auquel il faut appeler les français
saluent les transports ça concerne le
chauffage enfin le confort ce qu'on
appelle le confort des bâtiments ça
concerne l'industrie c'est ça les gros
geste en ce qui concerne l'énergie
débranchez le wifi ça fait partie des
petits gestes mais je peux vous poser
une question bête ça veut dire que vous
par exemple à la maison vous dites ça
sert à rien les petits surtout pas à
grand chose donc je sais rien je
débranche pas méprise ou au contraire
vous considérez qu'il faut être j'allais
dire parfait y compris chez soi y
compris si ça ne pèse que dans une
partie du total pour une partie du total
pour être très franc par exemple je ne
dérange pas le wifi la nuit oui je
pourrais vous prenez l'avion non qu'est
ce que vous ne faites pas ou plus j'ai
arrêté la voiture pour les déplacements
quotidiens là vous êtes venus commence
jusqu'aux studios de france info métro
je l'apprends
exceptionnellement est un peu à mon
corps défendant pour les loisirs
j'ai significativement baissé ma
consommation de viande je souhaite c'est
à dire significativement de moins de
viande rouge possible c'est un petit en
kg par an
mais oui effectivement pour quelqu'un
qui a inventé le bien car vous ne
pourriez
j'achète le moins d'objets possibles
enfin bon ça c'est pas très dur parce
que j'ai pas besoin de le forcer
voilà je baisse le thermostat le plus
possible enfin voilà détruit cesser
d'essayer des trucs de cette nature
après il me reste encore à faire des
gros travaux immobiliers il aya médias
c'est-à-dire isolé logement oui beaucoup
de français notamment mais dont il ya
donc il ya un crochet ce sont
essentiellement là dedans il ya un outil
qui permet de savoir quels sont les
postes qui sont importants qui s'appelle
l'empreinte carbone personnel il ya un
certain nombre d'applications qui
permettent de calculer ce genre de
choses et l'empreinte carbone personnel
elle permet de voir où sont les gros
postes d'émissions qui correspondent
très souvent sauf pour l'agriculture ou
gros postes de consommation d'énergie
voilà et donc là on voit où est-ce qu'il
va falloir qu'on fasse des efforts jean
marc jancovici invité de france info
jusqu'à 9 heures le fil info à 8h40
enceinte et une toute petite minute avec
maureen fuyards
alors que la communauté internationale
craint un incident nucléaire à cause de
bombardement sur le site une équipe de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique est en route pour visiter la
centrale nucléaire de zappos ridja en
ukraine centrale occupée par les russes
depuis six mois et dans ce contexte
sensible de guerre en ukraine le prix de
l'énergie flambe aussi en france
l'énergie qui se fait aussi plus rare
elisabeth bornes va demander aux
entreprises de réduire de 10 % leur
consommation demande de la première
ministre formulée au rendez vous de
rentrée du medef le syndicat des patrons
à paris cet après midi christian estrosi
le maire de nice va saisir le procureur
de la république pour des messages qu'il
juge ignobles sur les réseaux sociaux et
portant sur l'attentât qui s'est produit
dans la ville qui a fait 86 morts et 400
blessés en 2016 ils en appellent dit il
a la responsabilité des diffuseurs le
pakistan ravagé par des inondations déjà
plus de 1000 morts après des pluies
torrentielles la moitié du pays est sous
les eaux l'aide internationale commence
à arriver lentement
france info
le 8 30 france info sabia bras kia marc
fauvelle avec jean marc jancovici
président du groupe de réflexion the
shift project et membre du conseil le
haut conseil pour le climat alors le
gouvernement a pour le moment renoncé à
la contrainte de recourir à la
contrainte pour les particuliers en ce
qui concerne la réduction de
consommation d'énergie en revanche pour
les entreprises elisabeth bornes doit
s'exprimer devant le medef cet après
midi elle va demander aux entreprises de
réduire de 10 % leur consommation
d'énergie risque de sanction c'est ce
qui est prévu aussi est la raison d'être
plus ferme avec les entreprises parce
que c'est là aussi qu'il ya des grosses
dépenses d'énergie
ça c'est très difficile de répondre à
cette question sans savoir exactement
quel est le dispositif qui va être
proposée par le gouvernement je vais
prendre un exemple tout bête qui est le
transport routier dans le transport
routier le carburant représente un quart
des dépenses c'est des entreprises qui
ont des marges assez faible alors si
vous arrivez à économiser 10 % de
carburant fait une petite règle de trois
ça vous fait économiser 2 25 % de vos
dépenses à recettes constantes ça vous
fait 2 5% de marge en plus je peux vous
assurer que tous les transporteurs
seraient ravis de faire ça si il pouvait
le faire d'un coup de baguette magique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour eux en
pratique d'économiser de l'énergie ça
veut dire soit d'aller moins vite mais à
ce moment leurs clients vous dira
peut-être qu'on n'est pas d'accord soit
de changer la flotte de camions ça ça
veut dire des investissements donc voilà
typiquement un exemple quand un exemple
très bien très bien où économiser 10 %
d'énergie c'est pas quelque chose qui
peut se faire sans contrepartie donc ce
que je ne sais pas c'est quelle
contrepartie est ce que madame bornes va
accepter ou pas on va souhaiter ou pas
et est ce que ça va notamment impliqué
éventuellement une réduction d'activité
à cause des prix de l'énergie actuelle
vous avez des entreprises qui ont déjà
fait plus de 10% d'économies d'énergie
sauf qu'ils ont aussi réduit leurs
activités plus de 10% par exemple chaque
fois bas par exemple les fondeurs
d'aluminium
produire de l'aluminium ça se fait par
électrolyse 57,50 ça consomme des
quantités absolument considérables
d'électricité
et aujourd'hui vous en avez qui sont
obligés de se mettre à l'arrêt à cause
des prix de l'électricité ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'obligation d'être vertueux
environnementalement c'est un tout petit
peu lié quand même aux affaires russes
et bien ces gens là ils assez clair
qu'ils les ont faites des économies il
faut bien voir qu'encore une fois
l'énergie c'est ce qui fait fonctionner
les machines et les machines c'est ce
qui fait fonctionner l'économie donc
réduire l'activité des machines sans
réduire l'activité économique il ya des
cas de figure dans lesquelles c'est
possible il ya des cas de figure dans
lesquelles c'est impossible donc je vois
là d'où je tant qu'on n'a pas le détail
de ce que madame bord mais est ce que
l'on a est ce qu'on vient de vivre à
jean marc jancovici ce sans contrainte
est ce qu'on peut faire baisser nous
collectivement entreprises particuliers
administration et tout le monde notre
consommation d'énergie
uniquement sur la base du volontariat
non ça ira pas assez vite quand on
regarde la vitesse à laquelle la société
va devoir évoluer il ya deux contraintes
en ce qui concerne l'énergie il ya une
contrainte ce que j'appelle aval
c'est-à-dire il faut limiter les
émissions pour éviter que les péripéties
que nous avons eu cet été ne soit qu'un
apéritif devant ce qui nous attend et
puis il ya une contrainte que j'appelle
à mons et que les combustibles fossiles
sont épuisables il se renouvelle par les
combustibles fossiles il faut des
dizaines ou des centaines de millions
d'années pour faire du pétrole ou du gaz
donc une fois que vous les avez sorti de
terre maïs en sortie de terre et puis
c'est fini quoi je dirais on peut pas
recréer d'autres et les travaux du
chiffre project montre que en europe
notamment la quantité de pétrole et de
gaz qui sera disponible dans quelques
décennies sera au mieux la moitié de ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui et ça pourrait être
beaucoup moins parce qu'en fait l'europe
produit très peu de pétrole et de gaz et
doit tout importer et les producteurs
exportateurs ils vont voir leurs
gisements s'épuisent et les signaux d
alerte se multiplient en ce moment donc
de toute façon il va y en avoir de moins
en moins et quand on regarde la vitesse
à laquelle tout ça va baisser que ce
soit pour des contraintes amont que ce
soit pour des contraintes aval ça doit
aller beaucoup plus vite la réduction
que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui il ya un moment que ça va
faire mal donc aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on
a c'est autres des gens comme moi qui
s'excite sur des plateaux de télé des
gens de bonne volonté à droite et à
gauche qui disent je vais quand même
essayer de faire un effort et on voit
bien que l'ensemble de tout ça ça va pas
assez vite
donc je reprends ma question il ya un
moment où ça va faire mal il y avoir
passé un
quelque chose de plus fort que le
choisissez entre les heures de nuit et
les heures de jour pour votre
électricité à des gens pour qui ça fait
déjà mal oui c'est cela n'arrive pas sur
fait déjà aujourd'hui mans vous et moi
on fait partie des cadres leurs biens
bien nourri de centre-ville donc on voit
pas avec nos sens mais il ya déjà un
certain nombre de gens pour qui ça fait
déjà mal est en fait ce qui va se passer
c'est que la partie n'a par des gens
pour qui ça fait mal va augmenter c'est
ça qui va se passer elisabeth bornes
toujours annoncé hier qu'un fonds vert
d'1 5 milliard d'euros allait être mis à
disposition des collectivités comment
elle donne l'utiliser ce ce fonds vert
d'1 25 9 euros pour 1 la première chose
qu'elle doit faire les collectivités
s'est correctement former leur équipe
vous savez il ya une très bonne manière
d'en rajouter au problème c'est de se
presser de confondre vitesse et
précipitation
et donc c'est de se précipiter vers des
choses qui semblent pertinentes en
apparence et qui en fait ne traite pas
le problème voire éventuellement
l'amplifient il ya un an le chili
project produit un travail a rendu un
travail qui s'appelait résilience des
collectivités territoriales et où on
essayait de faire un certain nombre de
préconisations pour les élus locaux face
à la fois à la décrue énergétique et aux
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
est notre première recommandation c'est
être consacré 1 % du budget des
collectivités locales à acquérir de
l'information et de la formation c'est à
dire que les élus les administrations
locales qu'on prenne le problème à
traiter comprennent ses implications et
du cou et les idée beaucoup plus claire
sur m voilà une fois qu'on a informé
toutes les équipes qu'elles sont quels
sont nos points on pourrait pour les
gens pour les habitants de ces régions
comment on fait bah on fait de manière
contextualiser la façon dont vous allez
répondre à la contrainte quand vous êtes
dans une commune de savoie vous avez un
risque de glissements de terrain et aux
par ailleurs c'est là que la nourriture
parcours la plus grande distance avant
d'être consommée c'est là vous êtes le
plus loin et donc le plus dépendant du
pétrole pour votre alimentation ça va
pas être la même réponse que à morlaix
par exemple donc il faut les élus locaux
ils sont locaux donc la réponse il ya
des éléments qui sont communs par
exemple avec moins de pétrole ya moins
de mondialisation et donc tout ce qui
vient de chine sera plus difficile
d'accès pour les savoyards comme pour
les bretons par contre il ya des choses
qui sont locales et très contextualisés
et ce à la manière dont sécheresse va
s'appliquer à l'agriculture à morlaix ou
bien à garges-lès-gonesse ça va pas être
pareil donc vous avez une et pour
comprendre ce qui est pertinent chez
vous il faut se former s'informer
acquérir de la maîtrise sur le sujet
donc la première chose à faire c'est ça
mais c'est un peu long et c'est là qu'on
tombe sur quelque chose qui est ennuyeux
c'est que le pouvoir politique central
il veut toujours des trucs baguette
magique qui vont produire des résultats
en trois mois pour pouvoir dire la
population regardent et comme on est
efficace et malheureusement la réponse
aux problèmes dont on est en train de
parler cd réponse lente parce que il ya
un gros besoin d'organisation il ya un
gros besoin de formation et ça c'est pas
des trucs qu'ils soient en une semaine
est-ce que la réponse pour vous jean
marc jancovici elle passe aussi en
quelque sorte par la fin du capitalisme
tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui ce qui
est absolument certain c'est que le
capitalisme financier mondialisé
a énormément d'effets pervers dans la
lutte contre x dans la prise en compte
des limites environnement ne pensez pas
qu à un moment les investisseurs vont
dire on va mettre notre argent là où
c'est rentable aujourd'hui c'est à dire
dans la transition énergétique je crois
que malheureusement prise de manière
globale sur la planète la transition
énergétique n'est pas rentable parce que
ce qui a fait la croissance c'est
l'abondance des énergies fossiles donc
dans un monde où les énergies fossiles
sont en décroissance rapide
ma conviction personnelle et sa douche
solaire ça peut passer que le pib est en
contraction bon ou vont les énergies
renouvelables c'est pas source de
richesses alors les énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui on a réussi à
faire la preuve alors les énergies
renouvelables tout le monde a en tête
photovoltaïque et éolien je rappelle que
la première est
la première source exactement sauf que
l'eau il ya de plus en plus de problèmes
cette année même la norvège qui pourtant
est un pays assez arrosé puisque assez
au nord à des problèmes de remplissage
de ses réservoirs de barrage
donc l'énergie renouvelable
hydroélectrique en europe elle
n'augmente plus depuis maintenant un
certain temps puis dix ou vingt ans et
il ya un vrai risque que ça se mette à
baisser à cause du déficit de
pluviométrie en ce qui concerne l'éolien
et le photovoltaïque aujourd'hui les
dispositifs de production sont pas
renouvelables du tout ils sont faits de
métal et il ya deux limites on va dire
qu'ils commencent à être de plus en plus
diffusés première c'est que déployer de
manière massive ces dispositifs la
demande un accès aux métaux qui est
fortement augmenté or les mines dans le
monde produisent de plus en plus
difficilement ou plus exactement ont
besoin de plus en plus d'énergie pour
produire la même quantité de métal dans
un certain nombre de domaines et
notamment le cuivre
vous avez une alerte de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie a maintenant
six mois en disant peut-être que les
mines de cuivre actuellement en
exploitation vont atteindre leur maximum
de production et le sens au maximum 200
papillon comme ici vous dites les
énergies fossiles c'est ça va ce taré il
va y avoir une pénurie est bon ben voilà
on peut pas les renouveler c'est normal
c'est comme ça ce sont des énergies
fossiles les énergies renouvelables on
n'aura pas les métaux nécessaires on
fait quoi on va devoir alors c'est
justement là qu'on tombe sur la sobriété
on va devoir faire avec moins donc on
est on va devoir malheureusement que ça
nous plaise ou que ça nous plaise pas
quitté une forme alors macron a parlé de
la fin de l'insouciance et de la fin de
l'abondance malheureusement il a raison
quand on regarde le mode de vie d'un
smicard français aujourd'hui comparé à
celui de quelqu'un de bien lotis ya deux
siècles on se rend compte qu'en fait le
smicard d'aujourd'hui a beaucoup plus de
choses donc c'est faire avec moins et
faire avec le nucléaire c'est là où
votre discours divergent de celui de la
plupart des écologistes en france
aujourd'hui je fais partie des gens qui
considèrent que le nucléaire est du bon
côté de la barrière je fais partie des
gens qui considèrent que le nucléaire on
peut l'exploiter même dans un contexte
de contraction économique ça s'est passé
dans un certain nombre de zones de l'est
après la chute du mur il n'y a pas eu de
problème particulier à ce moment là je
fais partie des gens qui pensent que le
nucléaire est une énergie qui est
paradoxalement plutôt plus low tech que
le solaire ou le photovoltaïque parce qu
on a besoin d'un système moins
sophistiqué globalement d'un système
électrique moins sophistiqués pour pour
l'exploiter donc je pense que c'est une
bonne idée je suis pas anti technologie
par par par nature par conviction je
pense qu'il faut faire le tri il faut
faire le choix et il y en a où ça vaut
le coup de jouer et d'autres où ça vaut
pas le coup bon on va poursuivre cet
entretien dans un instant une toute
petite minute le temps du fil info à
8h51 avec maureen chouinard et on vous
retrouve juste après jean marc jancovici
on n'a pas attendu la première ministre
pour rentrer dans la sobriété lance ce
matin geoffroy roux de bézieux le
président du medef le syndicat des
patrons elisabeth band sera avec lui cet
après-midi pour prononcer un discours et
demandé aux entreprises de réduire leur
consommation d'énergie de 10 % la nasa
s'apprête à faire elle a lancé la
mission à artemis vers la lune une fusée
géante 100 mètres de haut cette fois
sans équipage et qui doit partir de
floride aux états unis à 14h30 heure
française
si tout se passe bien quatre astronautes
grimperont à bord pour une mission
équivalente de survol lunaire en 2024 il
a passé une première nuit en prison un
étudiant de 19 ans un pompier volontaire
mise en examen pour destruction par
incendie la police le soupçonne d'une
trentaine de départs de feu dans le
médoc en gironde cet été il encourt une
peine de 15 ans de prison c'est neymar
qui sauve le psg penalty réussi du
parisien et finalement c'est un match
nul contre monaco pour la rencontre de
clôture de la 4e journée de ligue 1 un
partout les parisiens qui ne gagnent pas
dont pour la première fois de la saison
franceinfo
le 8 30 france info samia ben radhia
marc fauvelle
jancovici président du groupe de
réflexion the shift project est membre
du haut conseil pour le climat on
parlait à l'instant du nucléaire
aujourd'hui la moitié des cinquante six
réacteurs nucléaires en france est
fermée à cause de risques de corrosion
ou d'opérations de maintenance il ya
aussi le problème de l'eau vous en avez
parlé tout à l'heure il faut de l'eau
pour refroidir les réacteurs et malgré
tout ça vous dit le nucléaire c'est
super alors vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure il n'y aura pas de solution
miracle dans cette affaire sayedi moins
de moins d'énergies fossiles bouaké je
fais partie des gens qui pensent que le
déploiement massif de l'éolien et du
solaire pour tous remplacés n'arrivera
pas parce que s'il y aura beaucoup trop
de limites physiques qui le 100%
renouvelable me croyais absolument pas
pas dans le pas dans un monde qui
consomment de l'énergie comme
aujourd'hui le 100% nous là vous savez
c'était exactement le monde que nous
avons eues depuis l'apparition de notre
espèce jusqu'à ya deux siècles donc il
n'avait pas encore les panneaux
photovoltaïques non mais les panneaux
photos aujourd'hui on fait avec
aujourd'hui les ponts a fait la
démonstration qu'on sait faire des
panneaux photovoltaïques dans un monde
dans lequel il ya du charbon pour faire
la métallurgie il ya du pétrole pour les
transporter depuis la chine pour vous
notifier les sages si on fait le don
donc il ya une imbrication entre les
énergies c'est ça que je suis en train
de dire et on peut pas déshabiller les
énergies et dire on va avoir juste des
panneaux photovoltaïques dans un monde
dans lequel il y aura plus de pétrole
plus de charbon etc et ils vont valoir
le même coup sûr ce que disait ça liens
dans les derniers instants la moitié des
réacteurs à l'arrêt aujourd'hui et des
fleurs qui sont censés les refroidir il
adore ça c'est pas un brin de la visite
l'air s'apprennent français quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans le match tout à l'heure oui oui non
mais quand vous regardez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le nord je parle pas de
loge part du nucléaire avec les
réacteurs à l'arrêt pour vous regardez
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans le
monde tous les réacteurs du monde sont
pas l'arrêt et voilà donc il ya un
problème français car le problème
français qu'est ce qui est de la partie
eau pour refroidir ça c'est un problème
qui induit un risque de défaut de
production ça n'a pas il n'y a pas de
risque de sûreté mais ce qui fait que du
coup le nucléaire ne serait plus une
énergie permanente qui aujourd'hui alors
les éléments de notre moteur elle est
déjà pas permanente quand vous regardez
la production nucléaire sur l'année vous
vous rendez compte que historiquement
elle a toujours été beaucoup plus basses
l'été que l'hiver se bâtir ne dépend pas
du soleil ou du vent c'est pas ça c'est
qu'on consomme moins d'électricité là en
l'occurrence l'été que l'hiver dans
notre pays où jusqu'à maintenant on en
consommer moins c'est pas le cas dans un
certain nombre d'autres pays par exemple
au japon n'en consomme beaucoup plus
l'été que l'hiver à cause de la
climatisation nous c'est pas le cas
donc traditionnellement l'opérateur des
réacteurs nucléaires les mettais à
l'arrêt l'été pour maintenant soit j'ai
un truc est tout à fait normal ce qui
est pas normal c'est le risque de
corrosion enfin exactement les défauts
de corrosion tian qui ont été révélés et
ça c'est un arbitrage qu'on doit faire
entre disponibilité et risques
d'exploitation et on a fait le bon
arbitrage en les mettant à l'arrêt le
temps de tout vérifier alors je n'ai pas
suffisamment regardé le dossier pour
avoir un avis là dessus parce que c'est
des dossiers très techniques donc c'est
l'asn qui gère se dit heureux et surtout
ce qui est absolument certain ça je suis
désolé de dire ça aussi c'est que on va
rentrer dans un avenir dans lequel de
toute façon on va devoir augmenter notre
prise de risque c'est à dire que la vni
le prêt à weeds a de toute façon c'est à
dire peut-être ouvrir des réacteurs il à
dire s'il ya une part de risque
exactement oui absolument mais vous
savez aujourd'hui grâce à l'abondance
énergétique on est on est dans un monde
dans lequel on se pare de tous les
problèmes à la fois justes on s'inquiète
un plateau m'expliquer ça déchire la
côte est de l'île centrale oui juste on
en crée un énorme derrière qui s'appelle
le réchauffement climatique met donc on
va devoir le risque en plus frêle et
reese le risque du réchauffement
climatique que les conséquences alors le
risque nucléaire est plus faible que le
risque d'un défaut d'approvisionnement
d'un défaut massif d'approvisionnement
électrique ça c'est sûr si vous avez un
défaut massive d'approvisionnement
électrique vous avez des systèmes de
communication qui fonctionne plus vous
avez des transports qui fonctionne plus
vous avez des systèmes de soins qui
fonctionne plus vous avez etc des
systèmes de chauffage qui fonctionne
plus et ça fait beaucoup plus de morts
tout ça que la quantité de morts que
vous pourriez avoir à cause d'un
accident dans le réacteur donc on va
faire du bénéfice risque avec le
nucléaire on l'a toujours fait du
bénéfice risque
sauf que sur le nucléaire on ne fait pas
nécessairement avec les bonnes
informations aujourd'hui on est plutôt
dans le principe de précaution sur new
york un appel le principe de précaution
est une autre manière de formuler que le
bénéfice risque y est toujours optimale
quand on a le risque minimale quelle que
soit la façon dont on gère les choses
mais dans le monde risqués et volatils
vers lequel on se dirige on va devoir
avoir une autre approche du bénéfice
risque malheureusement vous président ou
vous premier ministre libéral jean marc
jancovici un ministre une petite
transformation ip fiable vers la
transition vous rouvrirez centrale même
si le ca les parts sociales et non pas
les airs dit non non non non non je ne
viole pas l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
par contre il faut changer les critères
alors alors une chose que je ferai
peut-être c'est d'obliger quelqu'un
quelque part je sais pas si ça doit être
là et c'est nous si ça doit être une
autre entité à produire des avis sur
l'arbitrage bénéfices risques est
aujourd'hui cet avis on ne l'a pas vous
premier ministre vous interdisez les
jets privés ou pas
le chiffre project a proposé de les
interdire dans son plan de
transformation de lait donné vous êtes
plutôt sur la ligne julien bayou le
patron des verts que sur la ligne du
gouvernement dont certains membres
disent oui on pourrait réguler alors
quels sont les avantages et les
inconvénients de faire ça c'est clair
qu'en termes de consommation de
carburant stricto sensu c'est pas
quelque chose qui est majeure dans le
pays par contre en terme de 100 pardon
de transport aérien 0 1 % du transport
aérien oui enfin c'est parti lui-même
pèse pour 60 % du total j'ai pas regardé
les chiffres mais c'est sûr que c'est
pas énorme par contre c'est une mesure
que j'appelle à effet de levier parce
qu'il ya un côté exemplarité dans cette
affaire à partir du moment où vous allez
demander à une bonne partie des gens qui
pensent sincèrement et qui ont peut-être
raison qu'ils ont ils peuvent pas faire
sans leur voiture pour leurs
déplacements du quotidien voitures
d'occasion ont donné l'exemple c'est
compliqué de dire je ne vais mettre
aucune contrainte à des gens qui
rentrent dans un jet privé parce qu'ils
ont la flemme d'aller dans un aéroport
normale et qu'ils vont gagner deux
heures et que pour eux quand même gagné
deux heures ça vaut bien deux du
d'émettre quelques dizaines de tonnes de
co2 c'est quand même très compliqué de
dire ces gens là je ne leur demande
aucun effort merci à vous jean marc
jancovici premier invité donc de 7
rentré de 8,30 france info merci et
bonne journée à vous merci